every one every city on tamal and we're
here at Gamescom 2017 where time has
just been playing Marvel vs. Capcom in
Finland very excited
I got hands-on with the final character
roster okay and it was very good I'm so
not surprised but I'm relieved to say
okay I was gonna say cuz you didn't
sound like it was a lot of conviction
that you're like it's very good there
was a period like as if you're a member
of the mob or fighting in community
you'll know that Marvel vs. Capcom in
finance had a tumultuous time could we
just talk about Johnny's face like I can
confirm is good they've taken the
criticism to heart
she no longer looks like half asleep
lady she is properly proportioned they
put some time into fixing her face and
she looks like pretty kickin lady again
now as everyone knows and loves her more
importantly the game overall looks much
better than the last time I saw it I
mean I had a lot of time I played it was
an earlier build of the game but like
they said at the time they're still
working on it and they took him to heart
the criticism that they were getting the
criticism being that it wasn't popping
in the same way that the other Marvel
games yeah especially Marvel vs. Capcom
3 that was very vibrant and this time I
played it and they had a few more stages
there they had the a current member the
names because they're mashups of Capcom
and and Marvel Worlds so like as god is
you know matched up with these that you
from Mega Man
so they have weird names and I'm bound
to get him wrong if I try but they all
really look nice the one that was my
favorite was one with MODOK in the
background giant MODOK and you're flying
in front of him and he's getting a bit
aggravated in the background which is
really cool but it's look sharp a lot of
the it's one of those games that I find
like it looks a lot better in motion
than it does in the screenshots yeah cuz
it's very like over-the-top and vibrant
and kind of bombastic and you only
really get a feel for that when when
you're watching it part of its visual
kind of selling point is overwhelming
you with colors and effects and sound
and that kind of stuff so there is a lot
of that there so I got a hands on with
the final character roster I was playing
as I played us briar I played as jeder
who's new I've heard since spider-man I
played some chun-li as well I was
playing against Peter Rojas who's a
Combofiend a well-known Marvel vs.
Capcom player he's not making excuses
making excuses I'm player one in all
this footage and I was doing the simple
combos and when we started I told Peter
not to go easy and he absolutely did not
go easy on me he he clearly dropped some
combos on purpose to give me some time
to kind of hit a button but he
demolished me I got to use a few of the
Power Stone power stones yeah
Infinity stones just making a Capcom
reference they're fine for the fans out
there and and I found it very quickly
like as they they kind of were selling
it it's a very open mechanical system
like it's very open to creativity and
coming up with interesting strategies
depending on your character pick and
your stone pick so he was doing a lot of
like cross unders and he was doing like
links and he's doing a lot of like
manipulating the stones in a way that I
didn't expect to do things like take
characters that are slow or have limited
range and kind of break those barriers
and move across the screen back and
forth in a really unexpected way yeah
like like I said I'm a very average
player but once it gets into the hands
of professionals I can't wait to see how
they kind of Bend in power systems to
figure out the kind of other elements of
it more vs. Capcom is always fun to
watch our ego because you can't
understand most things that's going on I
feel like this is gonna be even crazier
it got to the point with Marvel's Capcom
3 that the same teams the same strategy
being used to commentating was a bit
weird but now I feel like the
commentators for these professional
matches are also gonna be having a great
time because everyone approaches each
character differently now thanks to the
stones and the kind of like the makeup
of your team the two versus two system
so it's gonna be a really good game to
watch as well as to play it's got a
simple command so anyone can play it
because I'm not a big fighting game plan
yeah you fight if you plan to be in
front of it Howard I guess that's that's
what the I think they focused on that
quite a bit because obviously you have
these characters that I am now more
popular than ever I was gonna say with
the MCU being the juggernaut than it is
it's assignable that they would want to
make that more yeah accessible for
people who are interested in the game
yeah thanks get in the car I feel
confident saying that if you just see
like the cover and you see like you know
spider-man there you see you know Ghost
Rider or anyone else like that you're
familiar with on screen and you feel
like oh I'm gonna play this you'll have
a good time because they have like
inbuilt commands where you just press
the same button over and over again and
it looks like you're doing something
incredibly cool but the people who know
what they're doing will say oh if I
start pressing it here and then do this
motion this motion this motion cool is
character in that's when it becomes
complicated and that is where all the
depth is so I feel confident at this
stage in saying this plenty of depth in
Marvel vs. Capcom Infinite and I feel
like it's gonna be a game that people
really dig into and figure out the
idiosyncrasies and the intricacies of
how the mechanics fit together to create
really like over-the-top really cool
battle stars so yeah I'm looking forward
to really sitting down with it I'm
playing way more and when it comes out
later on this year and I reckon the
community is gonna have a much better
time than they might have thought
initially yeah so that's my that's my
opinion on Marvel versus capital with
and I'm excited now yeah I'm excited
about it now I was a little tentative
going into it especially given the kind
of like drama has been surrounding it
but I feel good now my voice is cracking
I'm sorry
well the more from this year's games
come make sure you keep your eyes peeled
to youtube.com slash GameSpot and of
course GameSpot its Marvel baby